[Music]
we are dangerously reliant in particular
on China for the production of critical
goods and that includes Goods as I've
already outlined that are needed to
fight the current virus and I think we
rely on far more Goods than we know the
absence of having these domestic
businesses that can ramp up production
to meet demand for these critical Goods
limits our ability to mitigate the worst
effects of this virus the result is that
the virus could end up being more
damaging than it needed to be new video
tonight from Wuhan China the epicenter
and origin of Kovan 19 supermarkets and
pharmacies there are reopening for the
first time since the city was shut down
in late January now that the number of
new people infected with the corona
virus in China is slowing the country's
Communist Party is ratcheting up threats
against the West with a particularly
nasty warning about access to
life-saving drugs aimed at the United
States and as Richardson reports for us
tonight it's not the only conflict
between America and China over the virus
rich a good evening Shannon the State
Department summoned China's top diplomat
to the United States as US officials
accused the Chinese government of
spreading conspiracy theories about the
corona virus this morning ambassador Wei
tian chi refused to answer questions
from us as he left State Department
headquarters officials here say they
objected to what they say is China's
blatant global disinformation campaign
on the corona virus
American officials have pointed to this
tweet from a spokesman for China's
Ministry of Foreign Affairs saying quote
it might be US Army who brought the
epidemic to Wuhan be transparent make
public your data us owe us an
explanation there's no evidence US
soldiers visiting Wuhan in October
carried the virus a senior State
Department official says China is trying
to deflect criticism for hiding
information about the corona virus at
the onset of mass infections in Wuhan
President Trump says the accusation does
not represent the views of China's
leadership I did read one article but I
don't think that article was
representative certainly not in my
conversations with President Xi and they
know where it came from we all know
where it came from
disinformation about this virus remains
a challenge Fox News is obtained a
recent State Department
port showing more than 2 million tweets
worldwide across six weeks earlier this
year spread coronavirus conspiracies the
most prolific lies that the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation created it and
it was manufactured as a biological
weapon officials here say they are
working aggressively to combat
international disinformation about the
corona virus Shannon
all right Richardson and the State
Department thank you